الجوله الاولى من الانتخابات التركيه باحت
بكل اسرارها معلنه عن جوله ثانيه غير
مسبوقه في تاريخ البلاد رجب طيب اردوغان
وكمال كيلر اوغلو يترشحان للجوله الثانيه
ومنافسهما ثالث
يخرج من الباب الضيق بعد حصوله على نحو 5%
فقط من الاصوات لكن المفارقه الغريبه
مشاهدينا ان هذه الخمسه بالمئه الخاسره
ستحدد مصير الرئاسه في تركيا هي هزيمه اذا
لكن قد تكون بنكهه الانتصار فلمن ستذهب يا
ترى الاصوات الحاسمه
قد يبدو غريبا ان اسم سنان اوغان اصبح
اكثر تداولا بعد انتهاء الجوله الاولى من
الانتخابات مما كان عليه الحال قبل
انطلاقها والسبب ربما هو انه بات يملك بين
يديه الورقه التي ترجح كافه الطرف على
حساب اخر في الجوله الثانيه وعمليا ستكون
اصوات داعمي اوجان حاسمه في الجوله
الثانيه بعد اسبوعين والتي بلغ عددها نحو
بل ثلاثه ملايين صوت في الجوله الاولى
يدرك جيدا قوه موقفه في الوقت الراهن
فسيناريو الانتخابات رفع من اسهم قاعدته
الانتخابيه بشكل كبير وجان حقق تماما ما
كان يصبو اليه مع بدايه الانتخابات فهو
كان يعلم ان حدوده في المنافسه على
الرئاسه منعدمه في ظل قوه منافسيه لذا
اقصى طموحه كانت توجه الى جوله ثانيه لان
ذلك يعني ارغام المترشحين المتبقين على
التفاوض معه والاستجابه للشروطه
فما هي يا ترى شروط اوغان اهم شرطين على
حد قولهما محاربه الارهاب واعاده اللاجئين
واذا كان الشرط الاول يجد استجابه لدى
معسكر اردوغان فان الوضع يختلف لدى معسكر
والعكس صحيح بالنسبه للشرط الثاني في
اردوغان يتبنى موقف العوده الطوعيه
للسوريين وهو ما قد يستغرق بضعه سنوات اما
كلتش فقد ابدى اكثر من مره تاييده لترحيل
اللاجئين السوريين ولكن ما قد يعيق اي
توافق بين اوغان وكلس دار اوغلو هي
العلاقه مع الاحزاب الكرديه حيث ان اوغان
يرفض اي تحالف معهم ويتهم الاجنحه
العسكريه للاحزاب الكرديه بالارهاب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات